我最近看到一個新聞，說一位前Google的經理人，叫Tucker Bryant，他做了一個「AI聊天機器人」叫ChatTJB。結果這個機器人啊，裡面根本不是AI，全部都是真人來回覆。
欸等等，你說什麼？真人回覆？現在大家都在瘋AI，他這樣做不會太奇怪了嗎？而且他之前還是Google的經理人，應該更懂AI吧？
沒錯，這點就是最出乎意料的地方。他原本在四月啟動這個專案時，就是自己手動回覆所有查詢的。後來他在舊金山花六千美元刊登了一個廣告牌，推廣ChatTJB。
六千美元？那廣告效果怎麼樣？划算嗎？如果是我，我會先想這個成本。
效果非常好。廣告牌在七月底上線後，網站收到了超過十萬個提問。而且，志工名單每天以約一千人的速度增長。現在，Bryant因為流量激增，甚至暫停了ChatTJB。
哇，暫停了？那表示需求真的很大，比他預期的還多。這點我就有點驚訝了。那ChatTJB的「AI」到底是什麼意思？既然不是人工智慧。
他說「AI」其實是「Average Individual」的縮寫，意思是「一般個人」。他想傳達的訊息是，你正在跟一個普通的、真實的人說話。
這樣一來，是不是會讓成本很高？如果一個問題都要一個人去回覆，那人工成本肯定不低吧。就算有志工，志工的品質穩定嗎？
這個嘛，他目前的模式主要靠志工。原文裡提到，光是志工就有一萬多人排隊想加入。所以，短期內他沒有直接的人力成本，反而是志工自己願意付出時間。
志工會不會是剛好遇到新鮮感，所以才這麼踴躍？這模式能夠撐多久，長期來看會不會有問題？畢竟這不是一個商業計畫，他自己也說這比較像是一個暫時性的藝術專案。
確實，他目前是把這個看作藝術專案，但他也沒排除未來的可能性。他說如果有合適的夥伴，可以讓這個專案持續下去，他也樂意談談。這顯示他看到了這個「反向操作」的商業潛力。
如果我是開餐廳或小商店的，我可能沒辦法像他這樣，用一個藝術專案來吸引志工。但我會想，我們是不是可以在自己的服務裡，多加一些人味？
怎麼說？具體可以怎麼做？
其實很多小店已經在做了。像有些咖啡店，店員會記得熟客的偏好，甚至跟客人聊上幾句。這不就是一種「真人互動」的溫度嗎？只是我們沒有刻意去包裝成「AI聊天機器人」而已。
你說的對。Bryant提到，他之所以會做ChatTJB，是因為他意識到自己太容易把日常決策交給AI，甚至問AI今天該穿短袖還是長袖，這讓他感到不安，他稱之為「認知投降」。
「認知投降」這個詞很有意思。很多上班族可能也有這種經驗，工作上越來越依賴工具，反而少了自己思考的環節。這個案例好像在提醒我們，在高度自動化的時代，人類的真實互動反而變得稀有和珍貴。
沒錯，而且我覺得他利用「AI聊天機器人」這個詞來包裝，其實是讓更多人好奇點進去，才發現是真人服務。這有點像一個反諷，也凸顯了人與人之間連結的價值。
這樣一來，對我們一般上班族來說，是不是也可以思考一下，在自己的工作裡，有沒有什麼環節是AI可以幫忙省力，但如果加入一些「人」的元素，反而能讓服務或產品更有溫度？
嗯，比如說，一個客服團隊，雖然可以用AI初步篩選問題，但最終的複雜問題，還是讓人來處理，而且是真正關心客戶的那種。這可能會讓客戶更有被重視的感覺。
是啊。所以這個案例，其實也提醒了我們，有時候回歸最原始的人際連結，反而能成為一種獨特的競爭力。